this week on brian ross investigates
a cia mystery was this former
intelligence officer and dozens of other
u.s personnel
targeted by a secret russian high-tech
energy wave weapon
i woke up in the middle of the night in
a moscow hotel and i woke up with it
with an incredible case of vertigo
you know tinnitus which is ringing in
the ears splitting headache
it's called the havana syndrome after
u.s personnel
first reported the symptoms in cuba but
there's growing evidence
it's the latest act of aggression by
russian president putin
the victims are not making this up
there's just too many of us it's
happened too many times
plus new details on the grisly murder of
a washington post journalist
last seen entering the saudi embassy in
istanbul
he was drugged he suffocated he was
uh and his body was carved up with a
bone saw
and the pieces of his body were put into
plastic bags and then burn
for the most part in a tandoor oven
jamal khashoggi's killers were put on
trial in saudi arabia
but investigative reporter mike isikoff
has new details
on what actually happened to them
they're not behind bars
it's a a luxury compound and one of them
was recently seen working out at the gym
plus
this week's winners and losers in the
media see if you agree with the choices
of the editors of mediaite
fox corp has been muzzling me to keep
certain information from you the viewers
and from what i'm gathering i am not the
only reporter
being too subjected to this
from the law and crime trial network
this
is brian ross
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always by my
colleague rhonda schwartz
and rhonda we begin with a real-life spy
mystery
whether the russians have been targeting
american spies and diplomats
with a secret weapon that uses high
energy waves to affect the brain it's
what's called
the havana syndrome rhonda
that's right brian and there's now 130
americans who've reported that they
believe they've been victims of these
attacks while stationed in havana
washington china and russia and we're
about to hear now
from one of the american spies who's
been a target
in what's been described as another
example of russian aggression against
the united states
invisible attacks on american spies and
diplomats
it's a medical mystery that is almost
certainly wrapped in the age-old and
high-stakes spy games between the u.s
and russia
there are growing suspicions that
russian intelligence officers are behind
a mysterious illness called havana
syndrome
the symptoms were sudden and shocking
sleeplessness
headaches inability to walk memory loss
cognitive difficulties individuals
suffering from it have reported a range
of
neurological symptoms there are now at
least 130 suspected cases across
at least six countries lawmakers are
trying to determine if the brain
injuries from the affliction could be
caused by energy waves
from devices used to extract information
from cell phones and other electronics
the senate passed a bill this week
offering financial support for victims
of this mysterious
illness in the letter which was sent to
state department leadership the
diplomats claim the u.s government has
denied
employees and their family access to
medical evaluations and treatment
rejected evidence of their injuries and
invalidated their experiences
and we're joined now by mark
polymeropoulos and mark thank you for
being here
this evening first of all how are you
feeling thanks brian
it's good to be here i'm actually
feeling a lot better you know i i
you know after after going public in
october of last year about you know my
need for health care
i did end up going to walter reed's
national intrepid center of excellence
which is you know the world's leading
traumatic brain injury program and
it was a month-long program where i saw
you know 18 different specialists and
and i left there
probably feeling 20 to 25 better but
more importantly you know it gave me two
things that gave me tools and it gave me
hope
and what were the initial uh symptoms
you had
sure so you know in december of 2017 and
i woke up in the middle of the night in
a moscow hotel and a five-star hotel
just two blocks from the u.s embassy and
i woke up with it with an incredible
case of vertigo um
uh you know tinnitus which is ringing in
the ears you know splitting headache i
felt
like physically sick but you know as
i've said you know and i thought about
it quite
quite a bit i served in in war zones
such as iraq and afghanistan you know
for years on end and
and but this this incident in moscow was
the most terrifying experience of my
life the vertigo really you know made me
feel like i lost control and so
that started a you know a healthcare
journey that until today is you know
it's lasted with a headache for three
years
you were forced to leave the cia because
of your health issues
and at the time this happened you were a
senior cia official overseeing
uh operations in russia do you believe
you were targeted by the russians
yeah so so the last job i had but you
know private retirement i was the acting
operations chief of
over what we call the europe and eurasia
mission center so i was responsible for
our operations you know
across europe everywhere from dublin all
the way across the continent but then
into eurasia as well which included
russia um
and so yes i do you know i believe i was
targeted because
of my trip there you know i was a senior
officer i was in the senior intelligence
service the russians certainly knew who
i was
and at that time we were embarking on
what we called you know the great
pushback against the russians after
their interference in the u.s elections
in 2016 as well as
what they were doing in europe as well
and so you know i think you know my
contention it's it's my belief
uh you know i've been out of government
for a while so i don't have i can't i
can't come to you with
with with actual you know intelligence
information on this but i believe i was
targeted because of my role
uh you know in working against russia
and at this point do you have a better
idea of what it was
with which you were targeted so i think
the you know
but well the answer is you know i think
we do um you know i think the belief is
that it was a directed energy weapon you
know the
in you know last year the national
academy of sciences put out finally put
out a report
um uh based on their analysis of what
happened to officers in cuba and china
and
and dr dave relman who was a you know a
leading stanford uh you know researcher
you know
he wrote the report and and in essence
it concluded that we were all likely hit
by
a directed energy weapon we have
neurologists on our
committee that said afterwards
in my entire career of reading about
countless hundreds and thousands of
cases of neurologic injury
i've never heard of something like this
so i think
you know that um combined with you know
subsequent
attacks on intelligence community
personnel all who were involved in
working against
russia i think in my mind you know at
least the conclusion that
the russians were up to something and
look they've had this this you know this
technology this weapon
uh you know for some time so you know
you put two and two together
uh and that's that's where you know at
least i stand right now
and do you believe it was targeted to
harm you or was there another purpose
perhaps to try to tap into your
phone or hack into your internet right
that's a great question i think the
first some of the first you know things
i thought of in my mind is that it was
exactly that
kind of a signals intelligence system
collection system that maybe was you
know
turned up too much um you know and that
certainly you know
is is a possibility i would never
discount anything uh
uh but i think that you know ultimately
over time i think we've moved
you know a bit towards uh the directed
energy weapon but
but look you know i think what's most
important in this discussion now
as we're sitting here in june of 2021 is
we're not talking about this being
psychosomatic you know
the the victims are not making this up
there's just too many of us it's
happened too many times and
and while well in the beginning a lot of
us were not believed by our parent
organizations whether it was the state
department or or department of defense
or
or the cia i think we've we've moved
past that now something really bad has
happened
but your uh symptoms were so serious you
had to leave the cia
well before you wanted to is that right
look i you know i so i could i retired
at 50 because i could have
but i was 50. so i had a lot more left
in the tank i didn't want to retire and
you know 50 years old i think you know
in this day and age you got a long way
to go after that and so
but but the fact of the matter is i
couldn't go to work
for a full day just like now like i have
about two or three hours a day where i
can really concentrate
um until the headaches you know which
i've had every day for three years until
the headaches get too severe and i have
to rest
but you know no doubt i couldn't
couldn't work a full day anymore
so i had to retire you've since written
about the lessons to be learned from
your
service in the cia clarity in crisis
what did you do about this crisis and
what are the lessons you've learned
being such a senior official at the cia
so the book is called clarity and crisis
leadership lessons from the cia and i
there's nine principles i came up with
um that i learned over failure over the
years you know this is this is not
something that i walked in with or was
taught it's something that
um that i developed over time but
ultimately you know the gray is your
happy place and so
you know you know when others want to
flee um
or when people have fear of ambiguity
fear of uncertainty that's a time where
a cia officer at least myself
um and many other colleagues that's
where we felt most comfortable so i
wrote a book i think it's going to
really resonate with the american public
it's not for a harvard mba class but
it's based on my you know my time in the
third world
and it can be certainly used uh you know
by the american public and what better
time to talk about it in the time of
kovid when there was an incredible time
of
uncertainty and ambiguity in the united
states in the world
and how is the cia doing today do you
think under a new administration
new leadership so i you know i i have i
was fairly critical of the past
administration
in my fight with them to obtain health
care um but i'll tell you that that
the new ci director bill burns in my
view is you know has been quite
extraordinary
you know on my issue in particular on
the issue of of
of caring for those who are affected by
the direct energy attacks but also
i think he's the right person for the
job now you know he's a career national
security professional
he was a consumer of intelligence so he
knows what intelligence can do he
believes believes deeply and
you know in things like human
intelligence which was my kind of my
forte
you know if you if you watched his
confirmation here and i think all of us
were kind of popping champagne cork so
there was someone that said in the media
that you know langley was celebrating
that day because i think we got a really
good director
um you know from my contacts inside he's
enormously popular and i think uh
you know he's the right person the right
time all right mark polymeropolis the
author of the new book uh clarity and
crisis
thank you for being here and thank you
for your service to this country
thank you so much it's good to be here
coming up new details in the grisly
murder of a washington post journalist
last seen walking into the saudi embassy
in istanbul
and what happened to the men who were
convicted of killing him
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime
trial network
tonight there are new details in the
murder of washington post
journalist jamal khashoggi last seen
walking
into the saudi embassy in istanbul and
until now
nothing has been known about what
happened to the men who were actually
convicted of killing him
all with close ties to the saudi crown
prince
to get the latest on this we're joined
by mike isikoff the chief investigative
correspondent for yahoo news
whose latest edition of conspiracy land
the podcast
deals with the grisly murder of mr
khashoggi mike
thanks for being here tonight what have
you learned that we did not know before
you know there are first of all i have
to say this was
one of if not the most grisly gruesome
murder of modern times a
a journalist a world famous prominent
journalist
who was uh savagely murdered
inside the saudi consulate in istanbul
um his uh he was drugged he was
suffocated
he was uh and his body was carved up
with a bone saw and the pieces of his
body were put into
plastic bags and then burn
for the most part in a tandoor oven
at the home of the saudi consul general
in
istanbul so you know just it is so
chilling just to
go over what happened here but one thing
we discovered is there is more to the
story more to how this happened
uh and um one of the things we
discovered
uh is we knew that a
a gulfstream jet
with a carrying a team of saudi
assassins a tiger team
left for riyadh on the evening of
october 1st
2018 landed in istanbul
at 3 30 in the morning uh on october 2nd
what was not known is that um
jet made a pit stop it stopped in the
middle of the night
in cairo egypt where according to
the notes that i discovered uh
in the um record in
in the court in a court record in
istanbul these are notes taken by
turkish embassy observers
at a closed-door saudi trial
that took place in saudi arabia is
those assassins were delivered a
lethal dose of narcotics that were
injected into khashoggi's left arm
hours later on october 2nd by a saudi
ministry of
interior doctor killing him within about
a matter of minutes he was effectively
poisoned
these lethal drugs were what
um killed jamal khashoggi so mike was
this a kill
mission from the get-go was always the
plan to kill him not to kidnap him
bring him back to saudi arabia you know
that has always been the central
question
what this new information uh
leads points to and there's other
lots of other evidence to back this up
as well is that it became a kill
operation before that plane landed in
istanbul before khashoggi ever walked
into the consulate and plus
one of the other new details we have in
this um
uh in this podcast is that
uh there was a on the ground leader of
the team a guy by the name of
maher a former a
800 former a saudi intelligence officer
somebody who used to work with khashoggi
in the saudi embassy
in london mutreb was selected for that
job
precisely because he had a relationship
with
khashoggi the purpose was to lull him
into complacency
now of course the saudi crown prince
reacted supposedly with or
put people on trial what sort of a trial
was that because you now have obtained
documents that sort of account for what
happened there we haven't seen before
exactly this was a closed-door trial
no press allowed no human rights modest
monitors allowed no public record
exists but what i discovered in these uh
in the court records in istanbul is that
turkish embassy observers
were allowed to sit in on the trial and
they took
notes from what the prosecutors were
saying and
it's a highly selective um
presentation by the prosecutors because
they have mutreb confessing
that yes he ordered khashoggi to be
killed
we have uh the the the assassins
confessing that yes they met with katani
uh before the mission began but
katani is never questioned mbs is never
questioned
the whole purpose of the trial was to
find
uh scapegoats uh in that tiger team that
could be blamed
so that katani and
mbs were absolved of all responsibility
and one other thing we discovered is you
know five people were convicted they
were originally sentenced to death in
that trial then the sentence was
commuted to 20 years
and what i'm told from two sources who
have been long-time
sources for us intelligence is that
these uh five convicts
of the murder of jamal khashoggi are not
in anything that you and i would
consider
a prison they're not behind bars it's a
a luxury compound
and one of them a dr tubegi the ministry
of interior doctor
who injected khashoggi with those legal
lethal drugs
from cairo was recently seen working out
at the gym
as a saudi style yes exactly
all right yeah not anything that we
would consider
a real trial by western standards mike
isikoff chief investigative
correspondent for yahoo news with
fascinating
new details on this grizzly murder in
his latest podcast edition of conspiracy
land
it's out this week and will run all
month long mike isikoff
thank you so much for joining us tonight
thank you great to talk to you
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media
see if you agree with the editors of
meteorite about what they say about the
local fox reporter who went rogue live
on the air
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the long crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of meteorite
and we're joined by aidan mclaughlin
who's the editor-in-chief of meteorite
which like the law and crime trial
network
is part of the dan abrams media empire
and nathan you chose as your winner this
week
jon stewart for his appearance on the
steve colbert show
the only coronavirus we have is in wuhan
yes where they have a lab called what's
the lab called again stephen
the warhand novel coronavirus lab i
believe that's the case
and how long have you worked for senator
ron johnson let me tell you something
very funny and right to the point aidan
really funny and also a little bit
controversial um which is why
uh junk stewart is particularly a winner
today
because this idea this theory um that
the coronavirus could have leaked from a
lab in wuhan as opposed to
having traveled from animals to humans
uh through a wet market in wuhan
um has been considered a conspiracy
theory by most in the media
uh for months uh since the pandemic
began um it was in fact
just a few months ago that if you tried
to post on facebook
uh any sort of mention of the fact that
uh
the coronavirus could have leaked from a
lab uh you would have your post
taken down by facebook um so jon stewart
going on stephen colbert
and saying that this is not a conspiracy
theory this idea that it could have
leaked from a lab listen we don't know
which is the which is the correct theory
um so we don't really have any idea
um but you can't say that one is a
conspiracy theory um because it has not
been debunked
and uh i think that was an important
thing for john stewart to say and it's
telling that colbert
uh sort of suggested that he was working
for ron johnson
in response which shows that you know a
considerable amount of people still
consider this a conspiracy theory
and this week's losers the local fox
reporter in houston who went rogue
on the air live let's look at this
before we get to that story i want to
let you the viewers know that
fox corp has been muzzling me to keep
certain information from you the viewers
and from what i'm gathering i am not the
only reporter
being to subjected to this i am going to
be releasing some recordings
about what goes on behind the scenes at
fox because it applies to you the
viewers i found a non-profit journalism
group called project veritas
is going to help put that out tomorrow
so tune in to them
and that's a fox owned station aiden
that's right so that is fox 26 uh
reporter
ivory hecker uh in houston um who is
calling out fox corp
the parent company that owns uh the
network that she works for
and she has apparently signed on with
project veritas a conservative group
that does these kind of things they get
people in media to turn on their
employers and
secretly record them that uh reporter
has now been suspended by fox 26
uh it doesn't sound like it's going to
be a great week for them if they're
going to be releasing
secretly recorded videos over the course
of the next couple days
they will feel the pain of veritas as
many others have
aidan thank you so much for being with
us here tonight and thanks to all of you
for joining us this evening on
brian ross investigates much more to
come next week and thanks to our great
crew here long crime for guineas on the
air
and off the air every single week
[Music]
you